[Music]
it's gonna change spying forever imagine
if I can make you wait for it drumroll
please disappear disappear yeah
disappear why are you saying it like
that for affair I'm totally excited
about it it's called biodynamic
concealment boom mic drop
good conceal this I mean you wouldn't
need a boat to shoot you would you make
exploding cufflinks you can blend in
anywhere
dude that's a mess it's okay buddy
hey it's okay don't you worry your good
friend Walters disoriented look at you I
can't not look at you Walter I can see
my butt and your face at the same time
that is so cool
fact pigeons have 360 degree vision now
nobody can sneak up behind you the fab
girl come on so great pigeons can be
found in every major city around the
world and no one notices them it's the
most perfect form of spy could take
years
consider it done
you gotta get to that balcony we're
gonna have to park or cat pass tic-tac
jelly roll this lesson yeah I don't know
what any of that means
now I never walk so gotta go come on
while did you can do this okay it's a
physics problem Walter come on basic
physics is just basic physics
[Music]
we can do this really hey what are you
doing you're a pigeon Lancer what a
fastest birds in the world don't put me
down Walter need to fly I believe in it
is another way boy don't you blow me off
just well you'll figure it out fly fly
you're flying
[Music]
yes
yeah eyes are deceiving you yeah there's
a thank you thank you
yeah you're not looking so bad yourself
back to work grab a Chris Teutons too
much it's probably the right amount
Lucas there you go
good to see you fellas give it to me did
you see that
never wash that hand again I feel
stronger like legit feel stronger can I
hold it yeah dude from accounting for
the winter lane keep my money right keep
my money right great man all right thank
you thank you so am I gonna get it guess
it's time to introduce myself
[Music]
just three ounces of pressure to the
vagus nerve and then look at your boy
sleepy night night Blanche sterling the
legendary spy who's always dressed to
impress
Walter Beckett graduated MIT at 15 and
works in the tech innovations lab there
are so many gadgets I want to test in
the field for example the inflatable
hook kind of a personal protection
device I've been developing this is a
vile waste of taxpayer dollars this is
your next objective none of our agents
can get close to him
I have something that can help it's
called biodynamic concealment imagine if
I can make you disappear hey Lance look
at me look at you I can see my butt and
your face at the same time that is so
cool being a pigeon can make you an even
better spy pigeons are everywhere nobody
notices them pigeons can see in slow
motion
that was tight did anyone else see a
pigeon and [ __ ] who fly up to 92
miles per hour don't you throw me
officers he'll figure it out
all right come we're starting it's about
to get messy
time to go sleepy night-night
I miss my hands I gotta stay you're
squeezing - Oh what happens in a
submarine stays in a submarine you know
you can tell when you're the world's
greatest spy non-starting everyone knows
the name
everybody loves lamb sterling he's a
grade-a spy he's at the top of his game
he is the James Bond of art world and he
is as cool as any character can be look
at your boys sleepy night-night who is
last selling cuz last I heard he was a
pigeon hey Lance unburden me right now
stop girl seriously what will does so
great is just bring such enthusiasm as
energy to the character I don't want to
be a part of nobodies wat get fanboy he
makes him so likeable because of course
it's Will Smith I miss my hands no he
said Kumble guy and he's also the flashy
guy so it's like fun to watch him do
both
[Music]
what happens in a submarine stays in a
submarine kids think I'm weird one day
your gadgets are gonna keep the world
safe tame weird em weird
Walter is a really happy-go-lucky kid
really really excited to make a
difference
the inflatable hug kind of a personal
protection device I've been developing
just a good hearted brilliant kid and he
had so much enthusiasm and he's bursting
with ideas I've been working on this
thing at home it's gonna change flying
forever imagine if I can make you
disappear why are you saying it like
that
referre Walter is very very different
from Lance who's into the begin the
middle the action and Walter is about
gadgets but what's most endearing about
him is that he's trying to make everyone
be happy and safe we can't shoot the
other good guys let's just pull over and
talk it out exactly can we activate
weapon
don't you blow me off you'll figure it
out yeah you don't remember me do you
huh
what can I say I meet a lot of bad guys
I'm gonna make this hard
so you know very simple white Killian is
the bad guy but Killian we really wanted
a villain that when he stepped on screen
gave me the chills I'd love to have some
fun we just wanted to paint him as
there's definitely a history with our
hero Lance sterling there's a revenge
plot that he's taking on Lance is a
classical good God in order for there to
be a lot sterling you got to have a
Killian last name unknown hey you might
give me a hand I'm innocent or a really
really menacing quality to our villain
and definitely raise the stakes for our
two heroes I'm gonna show you can't
imagine
hello agent sterling let the beat drop
[Music]
we were writing it we had it done in our
heads for our hands like spirit of the
movie which is really about
companionship sticking together
different skill sets you got on the
drums and just started jamming and
Europe developing these lyrics and
you're just following along in that what
so once that came about is like I mean
we stopped like yeah that's gonna be the
vibe the melodies were so strong that it
just dictated everything else had
nowhere soulful funky stuff and it was
like a match made in heaven
but then let's get weird
[Music]
but then there were two
[Music]